indicios suficientes para abrirle un
proceso penal por desaparición forzada
ocho militares mexicanos fueron
detenidos por su posible participación
en el caso a yosinapa así lo confirmó el
subsecretario de derechos humanos de
México Alejandro encías el juzgado
segundo de procesos penales federales
ubicado en Toluca decretó auto de forma
al prisión en contra de los 8 militares
detenidos por el delito de desaparición
forzada de los 43 normalistas de
Ayotzinapa la detención de los militares
ahora encerrados en una prisión militar
ocurrió Un día después de que una jueza
liberara 16 órdenes de aprensión contra
militares Implicados En el caso de los
43 estudiantes de iosinapa desaparecidos
en septiembre de 2014 casi 9 años
después como cada 26 sus familiares
volvieron a las calles para exigirle al
Estado de México el enjuiciamiento de
los militares y Justicia para las
víctimas Ojalá estas personas que se
dejaron detenidas Ojalá este no puedan
dar alguna línea donde donde se pueden
encontrar los muchachos y pues más que
nada que se castiguen a los culpables
porque pues esto no puede seguir así lo
único que esperamos es encontrar la la
verdad y el paradero de los muchachos
según la investigación oficial las
fuerzas de seguridad mexicanas
detuvieron a los estudiantes para
después entregárselos a un grupo
narcotraficante que lo sabría asesinado
y quemado la cidh denuncia de más el uso
de tortura y la comisión especial del
caso creada durante el gobierno de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador concluyó que
el gobierno anterior coludió para
encubrirlo y atribuye al General José
Rodríguez Pérez procesado por delito de
delincuencia organizada la orden de
asesinato y desaparición